this ball light your house
this bulb this bulb this bulb will help
reverse the effects of global warming
better the lives of people and animals
everywhere
not to mention reduce your electric
bills substantially over time oh yeah
I'm gonna light your house too everyone
in America replaced just one light bulb
in their house with this little guy it
would be like taking a million cars off
the road over the course of the year
this bulb will prevent one thousand five
one thousand pounds 1,000 pounds of
carbon dioxide greenhouse emissions for
being put into the atmosphere how many
light bulbs does it take to make a
difference one one this goal will help
save dogs cats water buffalo redwood
forests polar bears
this light bulb will help save my fish
my baby the country my grandmother my
children and you this bowl this bulb
this bulb can help save the planet